you had twitter within minutes you had
YouTube within minutes and and somehow
we're trying to say that oh it's an
automatic filtering system wrong that's
not how what did someone knew that this
video was coming right and was waiting
for it to happen
glad to have you here so watch I
shouldn't say I'm glad have minor panic
attack earlier today we had a lot of a
lot of crap hit the fan so for people
watching this who aren't mug Club
members yet on YouTube last night's
video did 240,000 plays in seven hours
removed due to a privacy violation there
you go we can see it up there someone
comes late this is where fan computer
went to South by Southwest and then we
were what we I was suspended from
Twitter for the exact same video being a
violation of their code of conduct right
I think the actual email said enemy of
the state known as Twitter yes enemy of
the state known as Twitter also Jack
Dorsey thinks you're but that was more
an aside well I mean it was just a
picture of a did they send exactly
assumption was that it was Jack yeah
well well they don't
it's Anthony Weiner actually works for
them he's just in him but he's a brand
ambassador um it's so explain this to
the to the audience for people who don't
know because we have a lot of things
that we're working on here behind the
scenes we don't want to just complain
about Twitter or Facebook or YouTube we
want to fill you in on what's going on
and in what actions we're taking and you
can take so what's their claim here
their argument is that people are upset
and they want to try and shut down
voices that they don't like so if you go
to the different platforms they're
saying different things you look at
Twitter specifically in Twitter saying
we don't like anything about what you've
done the problem is is that the way that
they've complained about it it was so
fast it was as though someone at Twitter
was sitting there waiting for the video
to come up yeah
so they could be like in know yeah yeah
and on YouTube immediately it was also
someone at South by Southwest didn't
want us there yeah I mean yeah there's
no other way to describe it I mean you
had Twitter within minutes you had
YouTube within minutes and and somehow
we're trying to say that oh it's an
automatic filtering system wrong that's
not how would it someone knew that this
video was coming right and was waiting
for it to happen shouldn't mention it is
alive and well in MySpace no yes exactly
MySpace but you can't find it let me ask
you this first off legally and then
we'll get into
and I and irony here legally uh this was
somewhat South by Southwest it's a
single party consent state right correct
okay
and we bleeped any profanity it would
even be fine for T V uh what else there
were no acts of violence I said violence
no ever have any names you don't have to
do but we did don't covered all those up
and still allegedly some kind of privacy
violation and there's there's a really
an expectation of privacy when you're at
an event like that where cameras are
rolling so we want to be clear about
that
ah here's the funny thing about Twitter
this it was a violation of their policy
hateful conduct and you and I know
because we've dealt with this for a
while this is the same Twitter that
allows tweets like this up there if you
look at them side by side as a matter of
fact bill knows this we asked Twitter to
review these tweets the ones that say we
have to bleep myself here unfortunately
like gasps the talking about killing
Jews it's actually it actually comes
from a neo-nazi website because they
hated me they thought it was Jewish
right they did anti-semitic tweets then
when they found out I wasn't Jewish they
said let's make him out to be the
anti-semite these tweets were actually
submitted to Twitter to review we said
these are libelous some of them are
death threats and it's not a violation
of Twitter's code of conduct no they
just said we could do about it you know
people they say these things right we
just let it happen and and yet here they
are years later right in some cases they
say it's their policy but here's the
thing we follow the actual law of the
land of the United States and we get
removed for policy these are actually
there's libel there's death threats
these are actually against the law and
Twitter allows them
that's exactly they they have no problem
whatsoever it's not even a matter of oh
the computer didn't catch it it was no
you were specifically asked to do a
review you reviewed it and your
conclusion was that statements
attributing genocide to someone make
fake okay but there's literally a fake
swastika tattooed on my neck what can we
do it's Twitter what we sense ven
computer in to identify as a computer at
a gender nonconformity Meetup can we
call the SS damn it that was a fake mean
we don't have any SS can we get some FS
so here's the thing it's so damaging by
the way damaging it wasn't it what it
was up long enough these tweets these
fake tweets mind you that UT Arlington
professor what's his what's his name
again as Charles Hermes actually you the
aims to try and stir activists to get us
banned from SMU right that's that's it's
now March 22nd you're going to be
they're gonna be they're excited SMU
yeah and he used these he's using them
he's posting them he's sending them out
to a network he's taking statements that
have been dommage orally proven false
time and time again even if you didn't
see that the original one was false you
could see hundreds of comments of fans
of not just you even people say I don't
even like steven crowder but I don't
like people being talked about and lied
about right in this context so even
people who aren't your fans are saying
how can we let the dialogue get to this
place and that's what this professor is
letting out but the problem is they
haven't really been proving demonstrably
false if Twitter allows them to stay off
if Twitter allows things that they know
are the complete falsehoods libelous and
they allow it to stay up upon manual
review and then something that we do
because it offends some people he may be
strong peih-gee is taken down it gives a
sense of legitimacy to things that are
lies and it removes legitimacy from
things that are the truth here's
something else too that we don't i don't
want to get into all of it because you
can tell me what we can talk about but i
tell you you can't talk about all of it
it's not a free speech issue but there's
there is we are business partners on
twitter because we spent money on ads
with twitter so there is an
inconsistency with twitter in taking
money for ads that we've run to free
their followers or campaigns or events
that twitter helped us design we have
dozens and dozens of emails of
screenshots of twitter actually creating
advertising campaigns to gain followers
they wrote the copy they took the money
and then deemed those ads a violation of
their own policies and removed our
privileges on twitter to upload they
wrote the copy those are the laws of the
state of twitter that's exactly what
you're living under right now is that
legal to do no it's it's the issue as a
deceptive trade practice we've talked
about this before when we were dealing
with facebook facebook decided they
wanted to do the right thing at that
time you i've had some other issues but
we're trying to work through them but
right but for twitter it's again this
issue of you sell a product you sell a
service you send emails you induce
people to spend money on advertisements
you get them to do it then you write
the ads you were property ads you
collect more money on the ads you build
up a brand you build up a twitter handle
all based on those inducements and you
take all the money and there you go new
right and but yeah but we already submit
the money so we're like now gonna give
break I think screener we actually have
a picture of someone who worked at
Twitter who's like no no Hollis it
looked like your your ads were frozen
but don't worry we were we were actually
still taking the deposits and charging
you anyway there's someone these are the
ads that several months later they said
these are a violation of our policies
you can no longer post cards or videos
they come to me right they walk up to me
they say hey you really should invest in
Twitter I said well why I don't really
know I'm getting well you can gain more
followers and the good thing with
Twitter is that it's not algorithmic you
reach your fault you put it up you reach
your followers and you know what will
even help you critten I don't know the
first thing about Twitter would you help
me create a few yes so this is the
problem you see their private platform
and do whatever they want that's fine
well you can't do is take our money that
we would invest elsewhere to your
platform and then systematically screw
us while allowing illegal content that's
libelous and dishonest it's it's a
complete about-face and the only way you
can explain it is if there's a certain
viewpoint that's favored and a certain
viewpoint that's not because that's the
only way to describe this or they have
to just admit that they have no idea
what they're doing right well what are
the other that's why I have a half-asian
lawyer bill Richman because it seems to
me as though this tale has more yet to
come boom there you go okay well so by
the way we don't have another platform
but we have mug Club ladders credit comm
slash mug Club it's not a platform but
it's a way to support us so that you can
keep us on the free plan we still want
to be on YouTube we want to be on
Twitter we want to be on Facebook we
want to be a thorn in their side but the
only way to do it is to join my club you
get the free late night show every
single day you also get the judge you
work with watch is a levin yep us Gavin
roaming millennial Steve there are so
many so we're adding more every single
day listen if you want to support we
don't have a patreon we're not taking
donations we're not starting a legal
defense fund what we've wanted to do is
create
so much value in the content for you
that you want to be a member that's
sitting with our cup out we're actually
giving you other than their with their
cup we want you to want to join because
you want to watch the content
ninety-nine dollars for the year and if
you're still not sure you're a student
you're a veteran your active military at
$69 but right now we're actually
offering a 30-day free trial so you sign
up 30 days free if you like it it auto
renews and then you get a mug by the way
people are asking you get your mug after
the 30 day trial we can't send you the
mug because then would be we'd be a crap
creek without a paddle so right now
there's a 30 day free trial lotto is
Crider calm slash mug club because we
want you to support the con and listen
we take your money and fight we take
your support for us and we fight so that
these platforms can be available to you
we don't want to just hide out on CR TV
we want to use it so that we can put
things up there completely uncensored
like the video right now it's gone from
YouTube it's gone from Twitter the only
place to find it on Facebook your mug
club member gone from Facebook but we're
going to continue putting out free
content and if you can't do that the SMU
show on March 22nd is completely free
almost sold out lateral credit calm /
tour I think you might make a special
appearance there and we'll keep you
abreast as this unfolds did you enjoy
this video here's the thing
you roll you're here this is the end of
it so we don't care because you already
watched it but if you really didn't like
it and you want to justify it leave a
comment below telling us why you didn't
like the video and if you liked us let
us know and subscribe to the channel
because that lets the overlords at
YouTube know that you know what you're
alright